how many of you write when write in
longhand when you have something to
write how many of you print
you don't know whether you printer you
what to do mix Oh
I'm very interested in technologies of
language of which writing systems stand
out although after and in time in modern
times the reproduction of language of
spoken language becomes of equal or not
of greater importance what intrigues me
about writing systems is the degree to
which a body of culture let us call it
does or does not make it across a
transition point between two different
writing systems let me give you an
example in the 1920s of the Turkish
government being a nationalist secular
government decided to abandon the Arabic
script which had been used to write
Turkish for the preceding No
ten centuries or so
the act was seen as a act of modernizing
turkey but you could also see it as an
act that cut off Turks from their from
their written heritage if you no longer
learn the Arabic script you could not
read anything that was written say
before 1920 in your own language unless
it happened to be transliterated into
into the new script and this had
interesting implications I became very
aware of this the first time I went to
Turkey in 1965 I was in a hotel in
central Turkey and talking to some
people and became apparent that I knew
Arabic and people would come up to me
and say could you write my name in
Arabic script because I've never seen
what my name looks like in Arabic script
so I would write it and then give it to
him on a little bit piece of paper then
they would take it across the street to
the antique dealer to find out whether I
had done it right now of course the
antique dealer could have done it by
himself but he wasn't going to spend all
day just writing out things in in Arabic
script for people but the the
satisfaction that these older people
gained from seeing their name written as
it once had been just struck me as being
very very touching in a way but I also
did a study of of Turkish names in
general what names do Turks give their
children and prior to let's say prior to
1839 most boy children were named that
by most I mean about a third of all male
children were named either Mohammed or
Ovid or the Turkish pronunciations of
those names or named for a member of the
family of Ali either Ali Hassan or
Hussein gradually that shifted as the
Empire became modernized and people gave
their boy children a much wider variety
of names but all the names they gave
them were in Arabic because when you use
the Arabic script one of the
peculiarities of it is that it has no
capital letters and therefore you can't
tell what a name is if you're relying
upon capitalization to identify a name
for you and Arabic has lots and lots of
words that are not would not have been
known to Turks in general so the safe
thing was to give someone a name that
looked like a name so that when you ran
across it you would say oh that is a
name than to say that's not like you
know Keshawn or Keysha or some name that
wasn't used in the 19th century for us
now it would look like a name then as
soon as you got to the point where young
turks were being taught their language
in roman letters instead of arabic
letters you had an explosion of new
names that had never been used before by
anybody
because they used short vowels that
could be expressed in Roman characters
they could have a capital letter and
therefore you had a completely new name
so that you had names like arrow for all
things that never occurred in Turkish
before and this became characteristic of
Turkey because that Turks have names now
that are dramatically different from the
names in the Arab world or the names of
Iran
whereas at one time they had names that
were almost indistinguishable from from
Iranian names or Arabic names and of
course one of the results is that Turks
using a Roman script that is used in
Europe that contributes to a feeling of
affinity with Europe that has become
politically important in the quest of
Turkey to become part of the European
Union when you change the technology on
the one hand you cut people off from a
from a previous technology because they
become dependent on only those segments
of that technology that make it across a
barrier of technological change but you
also open up new possibilities because
the new technology may may create a
linkage in some direction that was not
previously apparent so that now you know
you have a striking difference if you go
to Turkey and you look around all signs
are in Roman script and you go to the
older buildings and the old graveyards
and you see the old Arabic script and
you realize that's you know what a huge
what a huge step that was
and I think much a much bigger step than
was anticipated at the time the great
question that we have now of course is
whether the internet will be a
transition point of that sort as people
stop actually going and reading books
and indeed as libraries stop buying
books and as books being published will
books become
irrelevant except insofar as they get
converted get digitized so they're
available online and of course you look
at projects like the one that Google is
a set and put books online and you
realize well those books are
english-language they aren't necessarily
in a variety of European languages and
you wonder will the technologies that
are made available to us now
end up cutting off our ability to have
access to earlier culture even now most
people would avoid reading old
handwriting's like from two or three
hundred years ago as long as handwriting
really was a universally taught skill
and that people were quite schooled in
both in the writing and the reading of
handwriting the idea of going to the
correspondence or the commercial records
of several hundred years ago was not
that daunting nowadays and has become
more and more daunting we always think
of course that we invented the printing
press changed everything
but of course would only changed those
things that were printed and almost all
right it continued to be done by hand
down until the 20th century it's just
that those things were printed as books
or pamphlets newspapers were the ones
that were using the new technology and
that's another point that I want to make
here and that is that the change in
technology may seem to have a certain
critical point
you say well Gutenberg invented the
printing press with Google type at a
certain point therefore that is when we
begin talking about the print era
but you can also make an argument that
the print era came in very very very
slowly and that most of the of the
communication and most of the cultural
contributions for another one to 300
years that were made without benefit of
the printing press so we tend to on the
one hand I think over een specific dates
and say give them more emphasis than
they than they deserve and we tend to
under state the importance of the
changes that we have a difficult time in
dating the there were two writings that
well basically there are three writing
systems in the ancient Middle East in
Egypt you have a writing system of
pictograms and that writing system comes
to it in the era after Alexander the
Great who died in 323 you have to say in
the Hellenistic era we classically begin
in 323 the kunio the hieroglyphic system
becomes supplanted so that the written
language of the Coptic Church the
Christian Church of Egypt is written in
an alphabet derived from the Greek
alphabet rather than an alphabet that is
descended from ancient hieroglyphic
tradition in Mesopotamia you had
cuneiform writing as a writing made with
wedge-shaped marks where you had the a
stylus pressed into a soft clay tablet
which then could be baked and be made
permanent so that we have you know about
a gazillion of these to have left the
last cuneiform tablet that we know of
dates apparently from seventy five
eighty four seventy-five see if it was a
tradition that that disappeared
in time as in the case of the Greek
hieroglyphics nobody knew how to read
anything in cuneiform writing
hieroglyphic writing the knowledge
disappeared so it becomes a technology
that could not be be reanimated sort of
like you know you have a disk that was
saved on a you know on a five inch
floppy on a Texas Instruments PC of
thirty five years ago and where the
world here we're going to find a machine
that will read that that disk I mean you
have the disk you know there's something
on it you can't hold it up to the light
and see what it says you have to have
buddy who has access to or personally
knows of the right technology so what
you have in the late ancient world in
the Near East is the disappearance
gradual to be sure but the disappearance
of two of the historic techniques of
writing and with it the disappearance of
everybody who could understand what was
written in those technologies a little
bit like those you know those Turks who
wanted to see their name written in the
old form but could it read it themselves
the third technology was the alphabet
the alphabet
you could argue supplanted both of the
earlier technologies but this of course
you know requires that you understand
what is meant by an alphabet an alphabet
was a series of character that
represented in a single character either
a consonant for in particular a long
vowel
it is attributed to the Phoenicians was
attributed to the fini in ancient times
why they say that they got their
alphabet from the Phoenicians yet
apparently is has parallels in a Semitic
language that is of that era that did
not use the marks but use cuneiform to
indicate the same sort of thing which
would be alphabetic cuneiform the critic
language in Lebanon but basically this
notion of a limited number of characters
you know 20-some came to be used by
everybody in by everybody I mean it
spreads way beyond the hearth plan of
the Middle East it shows up in India it
shows Central Asia shows up in Mongolia
shows up in Europe it was a good system
the Greeks are often credited with
perfecting the system by creating a
series of letters that were short vowels
so that you could express you could
write down both the short vowel and the
long vowel and that made it supposedly
more complete although if you text
something today you realize that you do
not need to put down all of those
letters and the Arabs and the Hebrews
and so forth have long realized you
don't have to put down all those letters
you know the Greeks invented a way to
clutter up the page perhaps but the
question is whether it was really
necessary or not there are certainly
crucial points where you want to know
whether you have a long vowel or a short
vowel but not very often
but anyway the Greeks get credited with
this stunning invention of the short
vowels and Greek becomes the Greek
alphabet becomes widely spread but a
more widely spread alphabet is the is
the Aramaic
Oh Eric
the Aramaic alphabet which is derived
more from the Hebrew alphabet them from
the Greek become spread throughout most
of the Middle East
other than Egypt and then spreads
eastward into Iran and points east it's
very adaptable and is used for many many
different languages and various shapes
from the Aramaic alphabet get used for
four versions of the alphabet dedicated
to two specific languages if you take
old Mongolian and you turn it on its
side it looks like Aramaic for example
at least is when Mongolian specialists
say because it comes from Aramaic now
the reason I'm going on about this is
because I want to talk about Hellenism
hellenism is a word that is used to to
characterize a wide variety of political
and cultural phenomena that are
associated with the period following the
death of Alexander the Great and being a
common place within the region that
Alexander conquered from Egypt across to
the Indus Valley Pakistan
Oh
there's a lot of debate over hellenism a
lot of scholarship has gone into on the
one hand trying to show the enormous
variety and penetration of Hellenism
only the Greeks and then a lot of
scholarship going and devoted to proving
that that isn't so
and question of Hellenism
it is a is a question that from a world
historical point of view is rather
interesting not only in and of itself
but in relation to later periods of
history when you get into say Imperial
eras where the language of a current
state or a state that becomes impure
overlord and one or another session
becomes a vehicle for culture in other
words the study of Hellenism
you could connect to the to the study of
the use of English in India you know
English is a Anglicism you know you say
who who uses English in India is it what
what is the class implication what are
the purposes of how does it relate to of
the languages all these questions that
arise with use of English in India today
are parallel to questions that was or to
phenomena that arose in the era area era
of Hellenism
and the same questions as to what does
it mean and why is it that way and of
course as in the case of the invention
of printing press by Gutenberg this is
all dated specifically to the death of
Alexander
first of all the the days of Alexander's
death doesn't have much to do at least
outside the realm of politics after
Alexander died you had a division of his
empire among certain of his generals the
two most important of for the purposes
of talking about Hellenism or general
name Ptolemy who took over in Egypt and
a general named Salukis who took over in
Iraq and Iran
in both families Anitra at least in the
heart of their respective bill the
Romans came in put rend oppose the last
of the solution
they are
kind of awkward to study the Ptolemaic
dynasty most of the Cape Colony
and most of the Queen's are named
Cleopatra
a lover of the homeland in the case of
the solutions
they're either named Seleucus or
Antiochus and so the two capitals city
honestly were salut Kea which is
basically you know on outskirts of what
is today Baghdad or Antioch is today a
city in northern in northern Syria for
the Ptolemies ruled from one city which
they developed as their great capital
and that was a city of Alexander there
is an between these these general
vacation of prospective capital cities
position four Hellenism is often
associated with of cities that were I
Alexander of his one of his successors
ah
and city had a garrison made up of
either Greeks for Macedonians massive
hoards of Alexander from the region just
north of and therefore it said well you
put down of Greeks or of acid for mixed
Greeks of Macedonians and you put down
these colonies all the way from from
India or northern Afghanistan at least
across to Egypt and these become sort of
I don't like to use where to word cancer
but that they become you know growing
nodule and that spread out from them and
our best represented by them
which certain model of historical change
a model of historical change that was
very riveting I think for historians in
the 18th and 19th centuries when
Europeans were creating cities and
populating them by my colonies from the
homeland and some of those cities of
course became great metropolis and we're
all now living in one of them a great
malignant growth that started with some
Dutch settlers a long long time ago and
then it just what big malignancies do
so you can you can say well
hellenization is in some ways akin to
modernization to the spread around the
world of the notion and the institutions
and the world outlook of identity that
begins in Europe or Europe in America
becomes implanted throughout the world
primarily starting in an important
cultural centers or centers that are
recognized as points of dissemination of
new thoughts this notion of
dissemination of cultural change through
true nodes that are nodes of expansion
has been studied fairly and typically by
by geographers and hellenization and
modernity or and the imperial enterprise
in place like India provide plausible
examples
but as I say this date of Alexander
isn't necessarily a very very what
herodotus
who's writing a couple of hundred years
before Alexander when there had been
though reconquest in the in the Middle
East although you did have Greek cities
in what is now Turkey those were cities
established for a long time by by
settlers he tells the story of a king of
the skiff Ian's all the skiff Ian's were
pastoral nomads who lived north of the
Black Sea and extending over to the area
that now would be in the southern Muslim
republics of the former Soviet Union
Turkmenistan Uzbekistan these are people
who were Horseman horse herders they had
homes that were portable in other words
you would have a a wagon bed that you
would put your your Hut on it and you
would move around to suit the motions of
your animals so forth and the language
they spoke while distantly related to
Greek was certainly not understandable
to the Greeks or or vice-versa
so here you have a skiff e'en king his
name is Scylla s--
nears what errata descent are you pay
these the skiff Ian King had several
sons among them this Scylla s-- who was
the child not of a native skin but a
woman of istria Istria is the area along
the of the eastern shore of the Adriatic
Sea what would now be Croatia or Albania
somewhere in that area
so this king out here in Central Asia
has a wife who is from this from the
Adriatic area
she herself taught Scylla's to speak and
read Greek sometime afterwards
area paid these and that note the same
area pay fees the area part is Aryan
just to reflect back on what I was
talking about last time some time
afterwards area pay fees was
treacherously slain by spar go pay fees
king of the egg after again thirstily
whereupon stylist succeeded to the
throne and married the wife of his
father whose name was oh boy now wife
was father of course is not his mother
because his father obviously had more
than one wife or concubine ah this apoyo
was asked if Ian by birth and area pay
fees had a son by her called or Wikus so
now he's married to his father's Widow
and he has a half-brother who is a
genuine Skippy whereas he is only half
skinned thean and a half mr. Ian
during his reign over the Skippy ins as
he disliked the skiff Ian mode of life
it was much more attached by his
upbringing to Greek traditions he used
to act as follows whenever he brought
the army of the skiff thien's
to the town of the Boris the Knights who
claim to be of Greek origin exactly
where this town is I don't know he used
to leave the army in the suburbs and
having entered the walls by himself and
carefully closed the gates
took off his skiff the undress and put
on Greek costume and in this attire he
used to walk about the marketplace
without guards or retinue they guarded
the gates that none of the skiff Ian's
might see the king thus apparelled
Scylla's meanwhile lived exactly as the
Greeks and offered sacrifices to the
gods according to Greek rites often a
month or more would pass before he would
change back into his Skippy enclose and
depart this he did repeatedly and build
himself a house in Boris thiness and
married a wife who is a native of the
place for this but when the time came
that was ordained to bring him to harm
getting to fate here
the occasion of his ruin was the
following he wanted to be initiated into
the rights of the back ik Dionysus the
Greek god of wine and fun
and was on the point of obtaining
initiation into the rites when a very
great prodigy occurred he had in the
city of the barista Knights a house of
great extent and erected at vast cost
round which stood a number of sphinxes
and Griffin's carved and white marble
onto this the God cast a thunderbolt it
burnt to the ground in spite of this
however Scylla's carried through the
initiation ceremony now the skin thien's
criticize the Greeks for their bacca
Crites they say it is not reasonable to
imagine there is a God who impels men to
madness
no sooner therefore was Silas initiated
in the back excites then one of the bris
tonight's went to the skin saying uske
thien's laugh at us because we rave
during these rites of Dionysus and the
God possesses us but now this diamond
this is the God possessing the believer
without this diamond has seized upon
your king too and he raves like us and
is maddened
by the God if you just believe me come
with me and I will show you the Chiefs
of the skin thien's went with the man
and the barista Knight took them
secretly to a tower presently Scylla's
passed by with the band of revelers and
the Schism saw him raving in the back at
stage they regarded the matter as a very
great misfortune they departed and told
the whole army what they had witnessed
when therefore after this Scylla was at
home again the skin thien's
put themselves under the protection of
his brother and rose in rebellion
against Scylla's now this tax has been
taken as a and then reasonably so as a
model example of Hellenism
of hellenization of non-greeks becoming
so enamored of the culture and life of
the greeks that they dressed like the
greeks they carry out religious rituals
like the greeks
and they get drunk and rave like the
Greeks but of course this happens a
couple hundred year 100 years before
Alexander the Great
so the you know this is one that there
are many examples of the degree to which
an attachment to Greek culture arises
well before the invasions of Alexander
and continues thereafter of course the
continuation is then attributed to the
cities that he established and to the
generals who established dynasties to
rule from those cities but the Pecha
matter is of the Greeks culture or
divine right rights or costume had
already attracted many people before
that so colonization appears to be a
gradual process that is punctuated in
the middle by an invasion that comes to
be taken as its point of initiation and
this fits into the idea that the spread
of Greek ideas in Greek culture was a
result of a military conquest that
brought new and better and more
more elegant cultural traits to the old
Middle East whether it was Egypt or
Lebanon or Mesopotamia or Iran this
construction of hellenization was very
appealing as I say to historians from
Europe in the 18th and 19th centuries
who could see it as a as a kind of a
model of what imperialism was doing in
their own world where you could conquer
a land and say afterwards that you have
brought a much higher culture to the
land the fact that in many cases
everybody who was there when you
conquered them and died you could say
well we brought in a higher culture -
the real estate that they are buried in
or something like that because in places
like the Caribbean all of the native
population died of the islands of the
Caribbean still there was something
particularly mesmerizing about the this
Hellenistic history very different from
the Roman history which I don't want to
get into now but as we'll see as you'll
see next week when you do the reading
for next week where the Romans went
their language did not follow and their
customs did not follow in some areas
they did but in many areas they didn't
and indeed it is more common to think of
Rome as a Hellenistic Kingdom than to
think of the areas ruled by Rome as
totally subservient to Roman to Roman
culture because Hellenism is seen
somehow as a higher and grand
under expression of civilization
archaeologically one of the strongest
manifestations of this was the
excavation in the 1970s by a site in
northern Afghanistan called AI Hunnam
that site is described by the excavators
as essentially a Greek cities physically
it has all of the manna station all the
manifestations of a Greek city and the
art of Hannam is Greek art it simply
happens to be Greek art that is being
made in in Afghanistan the the rulers of
northern Afghanistan after Alexander
were not the solutions because the
Salukis
while they have ruled the eastern
territories never had control of
northern Afghanistan that was a separate
Kingdom found his Bactria and the rulers
of Bactria claimed Greek or Macedonian
background and if you ever get into the
study of ancient coinage one of the
great glories of ancient coinage
consists of the Greek of the the coins
from from Greek bacteria large coins
with magnificent detailed portraits of
the rulers
so no question about that the Greek art
spread to ihum and it is also fairly
clear that in the course of time the
artists of I Hannam or other places in
Afghanistan became drawn into the circle
of people who were following a new
religion that starts up around 500 BC or
so and that's a religion of Buddhism so
you find that the earliest Buddhist
images the earliest images of the Buddha
or followers of the Buddha appear to be
Greek and in some cases are almost
indistinguishable from Greek art this
takes place in the Western sort of the
northwestern part of Pakistan which is
now basically a no-go zone because you
get killed but it's the area around the
shower which which was known in H times
as Gandara yeah
economist in president Afghanistan its
monoi it's northeast of the city of
mazar-e-sharif in northern Afghanistan
near the Oxus River which forms the
boundary between Afghanistan and
Tajikistan in that area the the city of
mazar-e-sharif which is the metropolis
of northern Afghanistan is the modern
form of the medieval city of Valcke
which is a derives from the ancient term
bacteria that goes back to the
Hellenistic era so you have a lot of
continuity there so here you have a
story about ask if Ian King who's from
Central Asia and here you have an
archaeological site dealing with
northern Afghanistan and you see the art
influences going into into Pakistan and
laying the foundations basically of
Buddhist art and to some degree of
Indian art altogether you don't have
that much before this time although you
do have a certain number of images on
seals from the Indus Valley it's over
but I've talked about those so you say
okay the argument that Hellenism spread
far and wide through the Empire of
Alexander even if it started before the
conquests it surely was promoted by the
establishment of these cities and by the
governance of these generals and their
descendants who succeeded Alexander
but is that you putting what do you
prove from that to some degree unless
let's say one test case was what
happened in Mesopotamia Babylon is one
of the cities that's conquered by
Alexander
it's just west of where Baghdad is today
and therefore just west of where salut
Kia was in the period of Alexander
successors a very key point in in Iraq
or the Tigris and Euphrates rivers run
most closely together so that you can
move easily by canal from one river to
another Babylon is on the Euphrates
River which is the further to the west
and the silho Kia and subsequently
Baghdad is on the Tigris River which is
further to the east and you might draw
inferences as to whether the rulers of
Babylon by being in the western river
we're more interested in Syria and
Turkey places they could reach on the
Euphrates and the ones on the Tigris and
these were more interested in Iran but
that since you can go from one to
another by canal it's not a huge point
one way or another in Babylon you have
rulers governor's appointed by the
Greeks who maintain them all
appropriate to the gods of Babylon and
documents continue to be written in
cuneiform an even more telling example
or counter example to icon 'm is in the
city of Uruk which is one of the ancient
cities of Mesopotamia going of course
Orcas where Ganesh rule in the ORAC
which it is occupied throughout this
period not a single word of Greek has
been found you know not an inscription
not an Austrian and ostracon by the way
as a is a piece of broken pottery that's
been used as a solid surface to write on
nothing
and yet you have a lot porrik in the
Hellenistic period
at you know it is raising questions the
the people who have talked about the
spread of Greek culture have looked at
things to selectively whether they have
looked at those things that that seem to
express the
the Greek influence and then shut their
eyes to those things that don't quite
fit that model so you could argue and
indeed there are scholars who have
argued that during the period when the
solutions are ruling in in Mesopotamia
in Iraq
you really have a continuation of the
coop culture and administration there
before Alexander came this doesn't mean
that you do not find some traces of
Greek rule because we know that the
Greeks did rule easily you will find
people giving their children Greek names
going back to what I said the very
beginning about Turkish names names are
useful device for looking at cultural
change sometimes you'll find that there
will be used seals that were used to
seal a document or seal a parcel or
something and those seals will be using
Greek characters but by and large it
appears that the Babylonian area of
central Iraq remains functioning
primarily in Jenaya form during this
during this Hellenistic period okay but
if that's the case
if if you're going to have Northeast
Afghanistan a pure seemingly pure Greek
city whereas in Babylon one of the old
central metropolis of the Middle East
you don't have this sort of evidence of
colonization then you get to question
with what what's the differential apply
to some places adopt culture and other
places down
we'll pause now while I think up an
answer to that question it say that it
is a very difficult question and one
with with fairly broad ramifications for
comparative examples in other times no
why does a cultural influence catch on
in one area not on another often people
will look to the question of what is the
relative standing of the peoples
involved other words did hellenization
catch on better in places that were say
had indo-european linguistic backgrounds
which would cover Afghanistan and Iran
but not without Mesopotamia or did it
have to do with the Greeks being an
urban society and in what cultures that
they would call barbarians like the
Skippy ins they were they just
outclassed anything else and the
barbarians came running to to attend to
them nobody
can answer that very well and Egypt
provides a particularly interesting
example because the city of Alexandria
is on the Mediterranean is a purely
Greek city it was founded either by
Alexander or by telling me the first it
is where they brought Alexander's body
to be buried body had to be stolen to
get it there it is where you had we have
a lot of information about the
organization of Alexandria as a as a
polis as a Greek city-state and yet when
you look at the assumption that you have
namely that it is at the mouth of the
Nile River is not true the Nile is the
the heart of Egypt flowing from South
North East Africa down the Mediterranean
Sea you think okay have a influential
cap for the Nile River we have contact
up to throughout the rest of Egypt
now there may have been practical the
mouth of the Nile River is a shifting
area where deposits of silt cause the
the nature of the river to to to ship
very unsettling in their abilities of
the mouth of the not have that were
written about described at certain
points and that have disappeared like
the city of to nice and you could have
made it closer to capital of Egypt our
city at the Nile Delta begins now say
the Nile flows from south to north and
then it gets down here and forms a found
old Egypt was here at the head of the
Delta
that was three of Memphis
the Ptolemies ruled over members but
they rule from memphis and in many
respects egypt becomes split between a
native country that remains in many
respects profoundly Egyptian and a
capital city of the Ptolemaic dynasty
that is the most famous Center for
hellenism health of any point in the
ancient world so hellenism becomes kind
of a you know a difficult phenomenon to
pin down historically certainly the
Greek culture spread although the Greek
alphabet did not spread all that far
most of the vets in the east were
derived from the aramaic rather than the
Greek well the Egyptian comes from the
Greek it's affected certain areas more
than others those areas in some respects
that have the most entrenched literate
cultures somehow maintained a degree of
vitality but over time of that vitality
is lost over time the Kunia form culture
of Mesopotamia disappears and the
hieroglyphic culture of Egypt disappears
all right now let me bring up a
comparison compare touched on just very
briefly last week or twos day I guess
and this is what happens in China now
what is striking about China as I
mentioned last night you don't get a
change in the technology of language the
language that shows up by 1700 BC on the
bronze molded into bronze ritual vessels
for the shang dynasty or scratched into
bones and tortoise shells in the form of
oracle bones that let that writing
system and indeed that language is
lineally the ancestor of the Chinese of
today and you never had something like
cuneiform vs. hieroglyphics versus yeah
you just have one one system
the system turns out to be something
that could be adapted and eventually was
adapted to other languages where to
Korean and Japanese some respects but
but for China which is eventually covers
an immense territory although initially
was focused in the north for China it is
primarily the writing system of northern
China
well
you don't when you have a spread of a
Chinese cultural mindset it doesn't
become associated so much with the
language as with a particular school of
thought of Confucianism so that you have
particular texts in particular
principles that spread over time
throughout China Vietnam Korea and Japan
I know talk more next week about about
Confucianism and early China I just
joined the comparison here with with
Hellenism hellenism some degree is a
social there's a famous battle of a
certain point that a spot where a Roman
general thinks that he is going to
defeat the Persians and he finds the
fairway way too many Persians and he
ends up getting defeated his headaches
and put in a sack and has carried up a
place where the Persian King in Armenia
and the head is thrown out on this issue
and held up by an actor who quotes a
line from a Greek play about how the the
prey has been caught by the hunter and
you know it's our India as a Persian
King but they still quoted in Greek
so you do have texts that are that come
to be known but that's so many
I mean it hellenism becomes more known a
melting pot of religions philosophies
and you know
worldviews than it is for having one
worldview or one philosophy or one
religion that is being imposed
everywhere so that when if the work
usually use
you think Hellenistic syncretism the
tendency you know this is like concrete
and sin means together so this is the
concreting together of different things
a God in Egypt will be identified as
being the same God as a God in Greece
and a God in Iran will be identified as
being the same as some other God in
Greece so that all of the Greek
religious legends become blended with
those in the in the area that is
subjected to colonization you get the
same thing in other areas of more
concrete areas of knowledge Hellenistic
science is considered to be a terribly
important episode s it thinks of it a
lot of it comes from Mesopotamia
particularly in the area of astronomy
from other areas it isn't simply
something that originated with the
Greeks and in point of fact most of the
major Hellenistic thinkers don't come
from Greece they may come from a Greek
background but they come from a variety
of places
so you end up with a syncretic culture
Greek literature which we now extol as
sort of the core of a Greek culture
because you have the Iliad and the
Odyssey then you have Greek drama to a
lesser extent Greek poetry Greek
literature doesn't travel well even
though there was this this performance
in Armenia you know really the defeated
generals head was thrown the Iliad in
the Odyssey don't get translated into
local languages
we are
Greek drama we have we have theaters and
show up archaeologically and presumably
had Greek dramas performed in them but
Greek drama does not get translated into
into local languages so you end up with
a rather selective filter that some
aspects of things that are closely
associated with Greece get transferred
into the areas that are so that our
thought of as Hellenized or subjected to
colonization and other other things do
not
why this is a case has really never
never been explained very well why do
some things work transfer better more
readily more have more enthusiastic
reception than others to some sometimes
it is associated with a Greek
institution that you have in these
cities and that is the gymnasium a
gymnasium was a characteristic school
for young Greek ma'am for Greek boys
where they combined athletic exercise
with a certain amount of learning and
with you know this is the route for
nakedness because all of the athletics
would be performed we be carried out in
the nude
prior to Alexander the gimm nauseam as
an institution does not appear to be all
that all that numerous or that
influential because many other probably
much of Greek education was not mediated
through this particular type of school
but in stick period the gymnasium is
spread to to all these Greek cities and
it becomes a education not just for the
weaker Macedonian background but also
for the elites of those of those
cultures so it's seen as a metaphor this
of Greek culture because you could have
a baloney 'm or an Iranian son of a
chief who who goes to a gymnasium and
becomes hellenized
it's not that when the grid empires
parts of the world in the night one of
the things that was often done was to
set up a school for the sons of chiefs
so that you would have a school that was
not open to anyone it's only open for
the elite and the sons of sheep um the
size and if they did well they could go
off and get a law degree and go back and
overthrow the crown or something but but
the idea was that if you if the sons of
the Chiefs are are influenced that will
be that will be enough I was thinking of
Gandhi and talking about this sort of a
chiefs under Ghost England gets a lot of
green goes back and over shows the crown
but I might he taken our own Edward Sade
who goes to a British elite school in
Cairo were here to become a rustic
dump of a philosophy meant to undermine
the imperialism that set up the school
that he and he went to it's kind of a
repeating kind of a kind of neat really
uh
you Greek culture was mediated these
gymnasium for whether this is firmed up
is is hard to determine but certainly
time off less or religion and late
ancient the world particularly Chris and
ultimately in the question of who you
know who are the heirs of the
Hellenistic era
this is debate we'll get into outline
more when I talk about Islam but one of
the things keep in mind is point has
been made by scholars about how the
great achievements of the Hellenistic
era were transmitted from into Arabic
and then there in the Latin they became
the intellectual basis of of the great
intellectual development of Europe from
the 13th century onward you go from
Greek to Arabic to Latin and it's
thought you know how nice
let's take it for granted that that's a
natural thing after all anyone who who
who has contact with Aristotle will want
to who his works will want to translate
him into his language because hey it's
Aristotle the world's most boring writer
but when you look there of the works of
it with Arab commentaries available to
them and they went to India no one in
India copied Aristotle they went to
China nobody in China copied Aristotle
they are or you can say about the
medical works of Galen Roman medical
writer from the point of view of the
Indians the Chinese is that thank you we
already have our philosophy thank you I
already have our medical system whose
only the Europeans
maybe they just realized that they
didn't know much of anything but also I
think it was more than they felt that
somehow that they were natural heirs of
these texts that they should translate
Eris somehow part of the story they had
invented for themselves of what European
origins were so this is a it is a period
of of dramatic change when you think of
the termination of the hieroglyphic and
the cuneiform cultures of ancient Egypt
and Mesopotamia but it is not nearly as
need a package as the term helen is a
hellenism tends to to convey the
transfer is not consistent it is not
complete and it is ambiguously related
to specific Greek institutions and that
gets to a point of saying well where
what is the long-term influence of this
hellenism other than in the sort of
mythos of a Western history so I'll stop
there next week we're going to deal with
the Romans I mean these dynasties or try
and think of something for you to read
or think about